the Transformers are back for movie
number five Cameron Mathison traveled
all the way to the UK to be the first on
the set transformers 5 baby the two of
you who's bringing the heat in this film
Wahlberg absolutely I can bring the heat
because I have a full military survival
but on work ethic edge Wahlberg yourself
every morning and plays 18 holes of
speed golf right when we started the
movie I was like dude I'm gonna come and
do that with you he's like well we get
up at 3:30 we work out and I'm gonna go
play at 5:00 I'm like you know what I'll
catch you on the weekend Josh and
Cameron chattered during an art walk
tour in East London a creative haven for
street artists and artist wannabes
that's good from street art to
Stonehenge well a replica anyway
Cameron's next stop behind the scenes
was to this dazzling reproduction of the
UK landmark
[ __ ] face says action and things go
boom the explosions are primed and they
are ready and so are we
for our transformers the last night
exclusive-or man here we go
I'm here with the man himself mark
Waldron stronger and action all over the
place here we got choppers landing
taking off we got a stone edge for talk
to potentially getting blown up today it
gets crazier and crazier than every day
we go on new to the cast
Isabella Mon hair she's got Mark
Wahlberg down see now that was good now
despite the word last in the title
there is no end in sight for the
Transformers a spinoff about bumblebee
is slated for release sometime next year
and a 6th transformers build has already
been announced for 2019
[Music]